happy labor day it's the last weekend of
summer unfortunately this is not a
normal labor day it hasn't been
a normal summer in many places tonight
politicians still monitor
and control the most intimate details of
your life where you eat
who you spend time with and where how
many relatives you can invite to your
wedding
whether or not you can hold your parents
hands on their death beds
the pretext for these social controls is
the chronovirus epidemic
we never thought it would go on this
long this spring you'll remember we were
told we had
15 days to slow the spread we thought
that meant
15 days were very literal but 15 days
became
170 days and it's still going people
like tony fauci showed up fouchy seemed
reasonable enough at first
in january he said that lockdowns of the
kind that
china imposed would never happen in this
country he also said you don't need to
wear a mask
he also insisted the virus wasn't a
major threat here he said all of that
watch bottom line we don't have to worry
about this one right
well i you know obviously you need to
take it seriously
and do the kinds of things that the cdc
and the department of homeland security
are doing
but this is not a major threat for the
people in the united
states and this is not something that
the citizens of the united states right
now should be worried about
yes don't worry about it it's totally
fine that's what tony fauci told us in
january by the way
we didn't take that out of context it's
not an isolated quote
we're not proof texting here as late as
is march
this march standing at a white house
chronovirus briefing tony fauci did not
oppose the idea of
gathering indoors for an indoor campaign
rally
but then more people started dying
federal officials panicked and they
elevated tony fauci from an advisor
a physician to a policy maker and that
was a
pivot point in american history the
hippocratic oath says do no harm
and it works in the context of a
doctor-patient relationship
but it does not work when you're trying
to run
a government and particularly not a
country as big as this one every speed
limit on every road is a trade-off
everything in life is a trade-off
between efficiency
and the value of human life if we cut
all speed limits to 10 miles per hour
thousands of lives would be saved but we
don't do that
sad as it is we keep speed limits higher
because we understand that some risks
even real risk potentially fatal risks
are necessary
if you're going to have a functioning
society that's just the truth
but tony fauci couldn't see that he
insisted otherwise so by april he was
warning that even shaking hands could be
too dangerous to continue
i don't think we ever should ever shake
hands ever again to be honest with you
not only would it be good to prevent
coronavirus disease it probably would
decrease the incidence of influenza
dramatically
in this country okay so that's extremism
it's not balancing the cost and the
benefit
of a recommendation or a mandate but
factory was clearly figuring this out as
he went along just like the rest of us
were that's not a sin
by the way everybody does it this was
new
but tony thatcher was a useful foil for
the democratic party and the media to
attack
the president so you weren't allowed to
point out that some of his
recommendations were inconsistent some
were just silly not all but some
the so-called progressives who often
confuse science for religious dogma had
finally found their leading man and they
wanted to protect him
at all costs jeff bezos's personal
newspaper proclaimed that trump and his
minions are trying to destroy fauci
destroy fouchy asking questions about
the mandates from a policy maker is now
destroying him it's absurd but dozens of
media outlets
repeated that talking point by the time
tony fauci described his lockdowns the
one that entired the entire u.s economy
hobbled the u.s economy as quote
inconvenient
nobody seemed to notice the washington
press court is nodded along they weren't
unemployed
in fact politicians began engaging in an
arms race to implement their own
inconvenient regulations chicago mayor
lori lightfoot promised that people who
went to parties
would suffer sterner consequences than
people who looted target
watch and this is how it's going to be
we will shut you down we will cite you
and if we need to we will arrest you and
we will take
you to jail oh if only she was that
angry at people
shooting each other on the south side or
people mugging pedestrians in the loop
but she's not
in los angeles the mayor eric garcetti
went even farther than that he took his
cues from the chinese government hosting
a gathering
in los angeles will cost you your water
and your power service the mayor decreed
these large parties are unsafe and can
cost angelinos their
lives that is why tonight i am
authorizing the city
to shut off los angeles department of
water and power service
in the egregious cases in which houses
businesses and other venues
are hosting unpermitted large gatherings
no science behind that hard to believe
this is happening in america but of
course it is once you give politicians
power they don't relinquish it why would
they
for mediocre people like eric garcity
and lori lightfoot people could never
find a job outside of say corporate hr
department where the standards were very
low
this was profoundly empowering they
loved it
the problem was it crushed the country
it crushed people
americans measurably divorce rates for
example soared by 34 percent
at one point newlywed separations
doubled domestic violence and fatal
overdoses
increased dramatically it may be a long
time before we know how dramatically but
it's clear
many people died as a result of this and
many more thought about killing
themselves
according to cdc numbers a quarter of
all young adults contemplated suicide
during the pandemic
ultimately the only group that found the
coronavirus to be empowering
were people who were trying to win a
presidential campaign and trying to
regain control of the senate and the
white house
they haven't tried to hide the political
benefits to the lockdown no they've
leveraged the fear most people have of
this virus
to gain political power back in may
house democrats
passed what they call the heroes act
there are parts of the bill that were
good
the parts that were transparently
political one part would send out
approximately 160 million ballots to any
jurisdiction in a state of emergency
that's the vast majority of the united
states the bill would also legalize the
practice of allowing paid political
operatives to collect
an unlimited number of ballots and
return them on moss to polling stations
that's called ballot harvesting it's
illegal in many places because it's
obviously obviously an invitation to
voter fraud
it provides opportunities to criminals
to intercept and manipulate ballots it's
happened
the la times concluded that california's
ballot harvesting law quote
does open the door to coercion and fraud
understatement of the week
that happened in north carolina the
state
invalidated a congressional election
last year in a ballot harvesting fraud
scandal
so for the people pushing it that's not
a cautionary tale it's a blueprint it's
why they're doing it
another chronovirus emergency bill by
the way known as the dismantle mass
incarceration for public health act
would allow for the release of more than
a hundred thousand prisoners including
violent offenders
of course the usual group rushed to
support sandy cortez rashida talib ilhan
omar
the chair of the house homeland security
committee benny johnson they all support
this
the prisoners are really released on
home confinement but their status would
not be revoked
unless they're literally caught hurting
someone that's
in the bill we're not making this up it
allows
incarcerated felons to leave prison and
stay
free unless they quote cause bodily
injury or use violent force against
another individual
so murderers get to go free but you have
to stay inside
indefinitely no one has told the rioters
that
they're on mandatory home confinement
they have to destroy their own stuff no
they're out in the street these commands
have been in place
since april we've known that this was
basically a political power grab since
then since the day a member of joe
biden's chronovirus task force dr
zeke emanuel told us so on television
watch
realistically covet 19 will be here for
the next
18 months or more we will not be able to
return to normalcy
until we find a vaccine or effective
medications there's
all that economic pain worth trying to
stop covet 19.
the truth is we have no choice
the truth is we have no choice meaning
the truth is you have no choice we're
doing this whether you like it or not no
one asks the public what they think
nobody cares
last month joe biden said that he will
lock down the country if the
experts tell him to what experts is he
referring to well
hardened partisan operators like zeke
emanuel this isn't science
it's dystopia how long can it continue